ingles handle more to give mitchell a
break off the ball that'll be something
to watch yeah and also depends on what
kind of defensive adjustments that
nuggets have made to get the ball out of
mitchell's hand well the aussie
rings the register with the three seven
nothing denver run to take the lead
adding value off the bench jordan
clarkson with the three
i was laughing when we were talking
pregame murray's saying hey we're up
three
diamond mitchell saying okay a lot of
attention on me we're only down three
where is the game clarkson another three
fifth
make that the seventh turnover for
denver
and bowler
so utah eight eight-point lead in the
ball again how do you close quarters
catch and shoot with o'neill for three
the extra dribble shaquille o'neal guy
he was a big guy that uh
you think seemed to excel every once in
a while it would be interesting to see
if shaquille grew up
a little bit later what kind of player
he would be with teaching
english hitting that three denver got
game one
in overtime jazz trying to even the
series mitchell down the lane with a
kick out
catching shoot three they made five
straight threes
come back at you i thought they've had
the energy of the entire night so far
listen there's no way directing traffic
with porter jr on the switch
two men to take the ball out of his hand
shot clock at three there's the skip
pass
oh neil out of the corner and there's
the adjustment
for the jazz you want to send two so we
could see exactly watch the double team
okay right here
just that little step up by royce
o'neill
okay allowed the pass to get there it's
exhausting
i think you're doing that i'm throwing
the penalty flag on you
really she's got to deliver the baby but
i'm saying it's you know
no you don't feel me on that no you're
the assistant coach